can i ask you just
if it's possible to do an overview and
just some brief
comments of wisdom on the process of
publishing a book
what's that process entail what are the
different options and what's your
recommendation
uh for somebody that wants to write a
book
like yours a non-fiction book that
discovers
something interesting about this world
so what i i usually advise is
follow the follow the process as is
uh don't try to reinvent i think that
that happens a lot where
you'll try to reinvent the way the
publishing industry should work like
this kind of
not like in a business model ways but
just like this is what i want to do
i want to write a thousand words a day
and i want to do this and i'm going to
put on the internet and
the publishing industry is very specific
about how it works
and so like when i got started writing
books was at a very young age so you
know i
sold my first book at the age of 21. the
way i did that
is i found the family friend that was an
agent
and i said i'm not trying to make you be
my agent just explain to me how this
works not just how the world works but
give me the hard truth about how would a
21 year old
under what conditions could a 21 year
old sell a book what would that look
like and she just explained it to me
well you have to do this and have to be
a subject that it made sense for you to
write
and you would have to do this type of
writing for the publications to validate
it and blah blah blah you have to get
the agent first
and i learned the whole game plan and
then i executed
and so the rough game plan is with
nonfiction you get the agent first
and the agent is going to sell it to the
publishers so like you're never sending
something directly to the publishers in
non-fiction you're not writing the book
first
right the you're going to get an advance
from the publisher once sold
and then you're going to do the primary
writing of the book in fact it will
in most circumstances hurt you if you've
already written if you've already
written it yeah
so you're you're trying to sell well i
guess the agent first resulted agent the
agent sells it to the publishers
it's much easier to get an agent than a
book deal so the thought is
if you can't get an agent then why would
you so you start with and also
and the way this works with a good agent
is they know all the editors
and they have lunch with the editors
they're always just okay what projects
you have coming what are you looking for
here's one of my authors that's the way
all these deals happen it's not you're
not emailing a manuscript to a
slush pile yeah and so so first of all
the agent takes a percentage and then
the publishers this is where the process
comes in they
they take also a cut that's probably
ridiculous so if you try to
reinvent uh the system you'll probably
be frustrated by the percentage that
everyone takes relative to
how much bureaucracy and efficiency yeah
ridiculousness that is in the system
your recommendation is like
you're just one ant stop trying to uh
build your own ant colony well or or or
if you create your own process for how
it should work it's not gonna the book's
not gonna get published so so there's a
separate question the economic question
of like should i create my own
like self-publish it or do something
like that but yeah but putting that
aside there's a lot of people i
encounter
that want to publish a book with a main
publisher but they invent their own
rules for how that works
right so so then the alternative though
is self-publishing and the the downside
there's a lot of downsides it's like
it's almost like
publishing an opinion piece in the new
york times versus writing on blog
there's no reason why
writing a blog post on medium can get
way more attention
and legitimacy and long-lasting prestige
than a new york times article but
nevertheless for most people
writing in a prestigious newspaper
quote-unquote prestigious
uh is is just easier
and well and depends on your goal so you
know like i push you towards
a big publisher because i think your
goal is it's huge ideas you want impact
right you can have more impact you know
but even though
like actually so there's different ways
to measure impact the world of ideas
in the world of ideas and also yeah in
the world of ideas it's kind of like the
clubhouse thing now even if the audience
is not large
the people in the audience are very
interesting as
it's like the conversation feels like
that has long lasting
impact yeah among among the people who
in different and disparate industries
that are also then starting their own
conversations and all that kind of stuff
because you have other
so like so like self-publishing the book
um
the goals that would solve you have much
better ways of getting to those goals
might be part of it right so if there's
the financial aspect of well you get to
keep more of it
i mean the podcast is probably going to
crush right what the book's going to do
anyways right yeah
if it's uh i want to get directly to
certain audiences or crowds it might be
harder through a traditional publisher
there's better ways to talk to those
crowds it could be on clubhouse with all
these new technologies a self-published
book's not going to be the most
effective way to
find your way to a new crowd but if the
idea is like i want to have a leave a
dent
in the world of ideas then they have a
vulnerable old publisher
you know put out your book and a nice
hardcover and and do the things they do
uh that goes a long way and they do do a
lot i mean there's it's very difficult
actually
there's so much involved in putting
together a book they get books into
bookstores and all that kind of stuff
all that stuff and from an efficiency
standpoint
i mean just a time involved and trying
to do this yourself is
there any process right like you said
they have a process they've got a
process i mean i know like jocko did
this recently he started his own imprint
and i have a couple other
but it's huge overhead i mean if you
like if you run a business and you
so like jocko is a good case study right
so he got you know
fed up with simon schuster uh dragging
their feet and said i'm gonna start
my own imprint then if you're not gonna
publish my kid's book um
but he what does he do he runs
businesses right yeah so i think in his
world
i already run i'm a i'm a partner in
whatever in origin and i have this and
that and so it's like
yeah we can run businesses that's what
we know how to do that's what i do i run
businesses i have people but for like
you or i
we don't run businesses it'd be terrible
yeah yeah or
especially these kinds of businesses
right so i i do want to launch a
business very different technology
business it's very very different
all right it's very very different yeah
yeah i mean this is like okay i need
copy editors and and graphic
book binders and i need to contract with
the printer but oh the printer doesn't
have slots and so now i have to try to
use i mean it's
i get so this i need to shut this off in
my brain but get so frustrated when the
system could clearly be improved
it's the thing that you're mentioning
yeah it's like this is so inefficient
this every time i go to the dmv or
something like that
you think like oh this could be done so
much better yeah uh
but you know and the same thing is
the worry with the with an editor which
i guess would come from the publisher
like who would who would uh how much
supervision on your book did you receive
like hey do you think this is too long
or do you think the tight like title
how much choice do you have in the title
in the cover
in the presentation and the branding and
all that kind of stuff yeah i mean
all of it depends right so when it comes
on the
the relationship on the with the editor
on the writing it depends on the editor
and it depends on
you so at this point i'm on my seventh
book
and i write for a lot of major
publications and at this point i have
what i feel like is a
voice that i've and a level of craft
that i i'm very comfortable with right
so my editor is not going to be
chicano is going to trust me and it's
going to be more big picture like uh
i'm losing the thread here or this seems
like it could be longer
whereas the first book i wrote when i
was 21 i had notes such as
you start a lot of sentences with so you
don't use any contractions because i've
been doing scientific writing yeah use
contractions
you should probably use contractions
that it was way more
you know i had to go back and rewrite
the whole thing yeah
but ultimately the recommendation i mean
we talked offline and sort of
i was thinking loosely not really sure
but i was thinking of writing a book and
there's a kind of desire to go
self-publishing not for financial
reasons
and the money can be good by the way
right i mean it's very
it's very uh power law type just
distributed right so so the money on a
hard cover is somewhere between one or
two dollars a book
so the thing is i personally don't but
you give up 15 to the agent
so i personally don't care about money
as i've mentioned before but i
i for some reason really don't like
spending money
on things that are not worth it like
yeah
i don't care if i get money i just don't
like spending money
on like feeding a system that's
inefficient
it's like i'm contributing to the
problem that's my biggest problem right
so you think that you're you're worried
about the inefficiencies of the
yeah the fact that uh like the number of
people involved
or the overheads yeah the emails again
the the the the the fact that they have
this way of speaking which i'm allergic
to
many people like that's very marketing
speak like you could tell they've been
having zoom meetings all day
it's like as opposed to a sort of
creative collaborators that are like
also a little bit crazy
yeah i suppose some of that is finding
the right people finding the right
people that's what i would say i say
there's definitely
and maybe it's just good fortune uh good
fortune in terms of like my agents and
editors i've worked with there's
really good people who they
see the vision are smart or incredibly
literary yeah
and yeah i had a great editor when i was
first moving into hardcover books for
example
it was my first you know big book
advance and
my first sort of big deal and uh he was
like a senior editor and
and it was very useful you know he was
like
we had a lot of long talks right i was
so this was my fourth book so good they
can't ignore you was my first
a big hardcover idea book um and we had
a lot of talks like even before i
started writing it
just let's talk about books and his
philosophy he'd been in the business for
a long time he was the head of the
the head of the imprint it was useful
yeah but
uh i mean the other frustrating thing is
how long the whole thing takes
a long time yeah but i suppose that's
you just had to accept well
yeah i handed in this manuscript for the
the the book that comes out
now like when this i handed it in i mean
over the summer
like during the pandemic so it's not
it's not terrible right and we were
editing during the pandemic and i
finished it
in the spring
you